Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, welcome to The Rest Is History, and it's the second episode. Dominic and I are out and about in central London looking at statues and asking keep or cancel. And in our first episode, we went to Trafalgar Square, looked at the statues there. Canceled George Washington, didn't we? We did cancel George Washington. And I think I cancelled, did I cancel Napier?
感谢收听《历史的其余部分》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周独家播客福利、无广告收听、剧集抢先体验以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。你好，欢迎收听《历史的其余部分》，今天是第二集。多米尼克和我正在伦敦市中心四处走走，看看这里的雕像，并决定是保留还是取消（keep or cancel）。在我们的第一集里，我们去了特拉法加广场，看了那里的雕像。我们取消了乔治·华盛顿，对吧？我们确实取消了乔治·华盛顿。我想我取消了，我是不是取消了纳佩尔？
I think I did. No, I think you cancelled. No, I cancelled Havelock. I cancelled Havelock. You tried to cancel Havelock. So we've now walked down Whitehall. We're by Horse Guards Parade. Along the way, our producer was fulminating with Dominic, arguing that they should all be cancelled
我想我是取消了。不，我想是你取消了。不，我取消了海夫洛克。我取消了海夫洛克。你试图取消海夫洛克。所以我们现在沿着白厅（Whitehall）往下走。我们来到了骑兵卫队阅兵场（Horse Guards Parade）。一路上，我们的制作人一直在和多米尼克激烈争论，认为所有这些雕像都应该被取消，
because nobody's heard of them. Very much the Ken Livingstone argument. And we've now come to someone who i think completely essentially proves his point it's a statue of someone i've i've never heard of it's field marshal his royal highness george duke of cambridge kg ccb etc he's a guy he's on a horse he's got a great statue tom it's a guy, he's on a horse, he's got a... It's a great statue, Tom. It's a great statue. That horse looks like it's having a piss. Dominic, who is he? I don't know who he is. Well, he's George Duke of Cambridge.
因为根本没人听说过他们。这非常符合肯·利文斯顿（Ken Livingstone）的论调。现在我们遇到了一个人，我觉得他简直完美地证明了制作人的观点。这是一个我不认识的人的雕像——他是陆军元帅剑桥公爵乔治殿下，KG，CCB等。这是一个家伙，他骑着马，这是一个很棒的雕像，汤姆。这是一个家伙，他骑着马，他有一个……这是一尊伟大的雕像，汤姆。这是一尊伟大的雕像。那匹马看起来好像在撒尿。多米尼克，他是谁？我不知道他是谁。好吧，他是剑桥公爵乔治。
You said it yourself. I mean, do you not know? Is that Duke of Cambridge as in the pub? There are a lot of pubs named after him, Duke of Cambridge pubs. Why? So who is he? He's Queen Victoria's cousin. And he was commander of the British Army for a large part of the Victorian era.
你自己都说出来了。我是说，你真的不知道吗？那是像酒吧那样的“剑桥公爵”吗？有很多以他名字命名的酒吧，比如剑桥公爵酒吧。为什么？那他是谁？他是维多利亚女王的表弟。在维多利亚时代的大部分时间里，他是英国陆军的司令。
Okay, I apologize for not knowing that. And he's widely known as the worst commander in British military history. So I don't think he ever sort of led it in battle or anything, I don't think. So why was he bad? But what he did was he opposed every reform, every reform, every attempt to make the army more meritocratic, to stop selling offices. So people buying commissions. Buying commissions, exactly exactly to make it modern uh to adopt new technology to adopt he opposed them all he famously said there is a time for everything and the time for change is when you
好吧，我为自己不知道这一点而道歉。而且他被广泛认为是英国军事史上最糟糕的指挥官。所以我觉得他大概从来没有在战斗中指挥过军队之类的。那他为什么这么糟糕呢？但他做的事是：他反对每一项改革，每一项改革，每一项试图让军队更加任人唯贤、制止买卖官职的尝试。也就是人们花钱买军阶。买卖军阶，完全正确，完全正确；为了让军队现代化、呃，采用新技术、采用……他全都反对。他有一句名言：“万物皆有其时，而变革的时机就是你
can no longer help it and he argued that they could always help it so now the other thing about him that's really fun is that he broke there there was a thing called the Royal Marriages Act, right, where you had to get permission to get married. And he broke the Royal Marriages Act, and he married an actress. And that meant that all his children were illegitimate. So all his children were bastards. Okay, well, that's quite interesting. Yeah, so the title didn't pass down to his children.
再也无法阻挡的时候。”而他认为他们总能阻挡。所以现在，关于他还有一件非常有趣的事，那就是他打破了——当时有一项叫做《皇室婚姻法》的法律，对吧？——你必须获得批准才能结婚。而他打破了《皇室婚姻法》，他娶了一位女演员。这意味着他的所有孩子都是私生子女。所以他的孩子都是私生子。好吧，这挺有意思的。是的，所以这个头衔没有传给他的孩子。
Okay, okay. So I'm just going to... Our producer isn't on a mic, but I'm just going to ask him whether he thinks keep or cancel. Cancel. Cancel. So Tony's cancelling it. Well, that wasn't enough for you, Tony.
好吧，好吧。所以我现在要……我们的制作人没开麦，但我正要问他觉得是该保留还是取消。取消。取消。所以托尼要取消它。好吧，这还不够，托尼。
Cancel on the grounds of irrelevance. Cancel on the grounds of irrelevance. I don't know. I think it's a nice statue. And I also like the fact... Well, I quite like the idea of having a statue to someone who's completely useless and he couldn't even marry properly but i think that that's in key in keeping isn't it with the first episode where we had a lot of
以无关紧要为由取消。以无关紧要为由取消。我不知道。我觉得这是一尊不错的雕像。而且我也喜欢这样一种事实……好吧，我挺喜欢这种想法的：为某一个完全无用、甚至连婚都结不好的人立一尊雕像，但我认为这非常符合第一集的主旨，我们在第一集里见到了很多
useless kings yes charles ii james ii yes george washington who of course beat the british um some generals nobody's heard of i think i think in a way that perhaps if we reframe the debate and say it gives encouragement to people who aren't very good. Yeah, the producer is rightly pointing out that he thinks this is absolutely ridiculous because we're in the ceremonial core of Britain. We're surrounded by all the buildings. So the old war office is there. It's just been converted into apartments. You know, we're in these fantastic sort of neoclassical buildings.
无用的国王，是的，查理二世、詹姆斯二世，还有乔治·华盛顿——他当然击败了英国人，嗯，还有一些没人听说过的将军。我觉得，从某种程度上来说，如果我们重新构建辩论框架，说这给了那些不太优秀的人以鼓舞……是的，制作人非常正确地指出，他认为这太荒谬了，因为我们身处英国的礼仪核心区。我们被所有的建筑包围着。所以旧军务部就在那里。它刚刚被改造成了公寓。你知道的，我们置身于这些极好的新古典主义建筑之中。
And I like the fact that we have a symbol of futility. In incompetence uselessness yeah i think that's very british it's very yes minister the french would have like napoleon or marshall nay wouldn't we and we have someone who can't even marry an actress properly yeah exactly i think he's very british yeah i i make you proud doesn't it yeah to a degree i suppose although it's not framed like that is it so people are very keen now on putting up um little signs explaining who people are and why they're there yeah so perhaps we need to put up a sign saying this man is here because he was massively incompetent because he's really useless so all right now now do you know this is on the left coming up here a very good statue spencer spencer competent eighth duke of devonshire okay i have
我喜欢我们拥有一个象征着徒劳、无能和无用的标志，是的，我觉得这非常“英国”，非常像《是的，大臣》（Yes Minister）。法国人会想要拿破仑或者内伊元帅（Marshal Ney），对吧？而我们却有一个连娶女演员都娶不好的人。对，没错，我觉得他非常英国。是的，这让你感到自豪，对吧？是的，某种程度上我想是的，尽管它并不是这样被包装的，对吧？所以人们现在热衷于竖起小牌子，解释这些人是谁、他们为什么在这里。所以也许我们需要竖起一个牌子，上面写着：“这个人在这里，是因为他极端无能，因为他真的很无用。”好吧，现在，你知道左边这个吗？走过来，这是一个很好的雕像，斯宾塞……
no idea so he's the duke of devonshire he's a victorian politician now he's an interesting person so born 1833 died 1908 he's better known as lord hartington he's very famous in his day so he's unusual and he led nice motorbike action there uh he led three different political parties at different times he led led the Liberals, he led the Liberal Unionists, who break away from the Liberals, and he led the Tories in the Lords. He was offered the premiership, and full of
斯宾塞，能力出众的第八代德文郡公爵。好吧，我完全不知道。所以他是德文郡公爵，一个维多利亚时代的政治家。现在，他是一个有趣的人。生于1833年，卒于1908年。他更为人所知的名字是哈丁顿勋爵（Lord Hartington）。他在当时非常有名。所以他很不寻常……那边有很棒的摩托车动作，呃。他曾在不同时期领导过三个不同的政党。他领导过自由党，领导过从自由党分裂出去的自由统一党（Liberal Unionists），还在上议院领导过保守党。他曾被邀请出任首相，而且充满了
facts, Tom. Have you been looking at Wikipedia? I have been looking at Wikipedia. He was offered the premiership three times and declined three times. So in other words, a man who three times could have been Prime Minister but wasn't, because he liked to spend his time pleasures of the turf, shooting.
事实，汤姆。你一直在看维基百科吗？我一直在看维基百科。他曾三次被邀请出任首相，但都拒绝了。换句话说，他是一个本可以三次成为首相却没有这样做的人，因为他喜欢把时间花在赛马场的乐趣和射击上。
Well, again... And wait for it. Wait. He had a mistress called Skittles who was... And somewhere in London there's a plaque to her
好吧，还有……等着瞧。等等。他曾有一个情妇叫“九柱戏”（Skittles），她……在伦敦的某处有一块关于她的牌匾，
and it says The Last Victorian Courtesan. So she was a celebrity prostitute and when she used to go riding in Hyde Park she wore a specially fitted, skin tight riding outfit and crowds would gather to watch her riding. How about that?
上面写着“最后一位维多利亚时代的交际花”。所以她是一个名妓。当她过去在海德公园骑马时，她穿着一套特别定制的紧身骑马装，人们会聚集在一起看她骑马。觉得怎么样？
Well, I'm going to keep him. He's a massive lad. Yeah, exactly. He's a massive lad and he looks good, doesn't he? Yeah, I mean he's got kind of... He's very Victorian. Nice beard. Great cloak, medals.
好吧，我要保留他。他是个了不起的大人物。是的，完全没错。他是个了不起的大人物，而且他看起来很帅，对吧？是的，我是说他有一种……他非常具有维多利亚时代特色。胡子很漂亮。斗篷很棒，还有勋章。
Why wouldn't you? So this is for the producer who says people are irrelevant. He is irrelevant, of course, but he's interesting, isn't he? Do you know what I think is interesting? Yeah, so he's nodding. He's nodding. I've won. I am the statue champion.
为什么不呢？所以这是为了那个认为人们不重要的制作人。他当然是不重要的，但他很有趣，不是吗？你知道我觉得有趣的是什么吗？是的，所以他在点头。他在点头。我赢了。我是雕像之王。
So we haven't cancelled anyone yet? No, we haven't cancelled either of those two. Oh, you wanted to cancel the Duke of Cambridge though, did you, deep down? I do, really. I mean, I think arguing for keeping him up just because he's a model of incompetence to encourage people, it's not really a clinching argument. Whereas a guy who had an affair with someone called Skittles. I like that. Yeah.
所以我们还没取消任何人？不，那两个我们都没取消。哦，不过内心深处你其实想取消剑桥公爵，对吧？我真的想。我是说，我认为仅仅因为他是无能的典范、为了鼓舞人们而支持保留他，这并不是一个决定性的论据。相比之下，一个跟一个叫“九柱戏”的人有外遇的家伙……我喜欢这样。是的。
And I'm happy to see that as a reasonable justification for keeping him. You see, that's what I think is so great about this walk, is that all these buildings, which kind of connote power and magnificence and might, but as you keep, you know, the actual characters, but these sort of ludicrous people from, you know, sort of Victoria. But it's kind of, I mean, who would be the, it's kind of like having statues to Nick Clegg or...
我很高兴将其视为保留他的合理理由。你看，这就是我认为这次漫步如此棒的地方，所有这些建筑，它们暗示着权力、宏伟和力量，但当你不断看到，你知道的，实际的人物，这些来自维多利亚时代的荒谬人物……但这有点像是，谁会是……这就好比给尼克·克莱格（Nick Clegg）或者……立雕像。
Yeah, Danny Alexander. Yes. Well, no, I mean... Richard Bergen. Kenneth Baker or, I mean, completely forgotten figures who nobody particularly liked. Okay, so here's another one. I mean, it looks exactly the same.
丹尼·亚历山大（Danny Alexander）。是的。好吧，不，我是说……理查德·伯根（Richard Bergen）。肯尼斯·贝克（Kenneth Baker）或者，我是说，那些完全被遗忘、没人特别喜欢的人物。好吧，这里还有另一个。我是说，它看起来完全一样。
An Edwardian looking... Oh, it's Thingy. Now. Now. It's Hake. This is a very good one. Is it Hake? Yes, it's Earl Hake.
一个爱德华时代风格的……哦，是那个谁。现在。现在。是黑格（Haig）。这是一个非常好的雕像。是黑格吗？是的，是黑格伯爵（Earl Haig）。
So I've heard of Earl Hake because I've read Gary Sheffield's book. Earl Hake. Gary Sheffield will be coming on very soon to talk about the Western Front. So this is, you know, the British commander at the height of the First World War, the mastermind behind the triumph of the Somme.
所以我听说过黑格伯爵，因为我读过加里·谢菲尔德（Gary Sheffield）的书。黑格伯爵。加里·谢菲尔德很快就会来谈论西线战场。所以这是，你知道的，第一次世界大战高潮时期的英国指挥官，索姆河大捷背后的策划者。
He's just been blocked off by a bus. Now incredibly controversial among historians, massive arguments for and against, seen by some historians afterwards as the donkey who sent all these lions to their deaths. Subsequently being a bit rehabilitated, I think it's fair to say. He's from a whiskey dynasty.
他刚刚被一辆公共汽车挡住了视线。在历史学家中间，他极具争议，有着大量赞成与反对的争论。后来被一些历史学家视为把所有这些雄狮送上死路的“笨驴”（donkey）。后来他的名誉得到了一些平反，我觉得这样说算公平。他出身于威士忌酿造世家。
He was very in with the court. He was a dashing cavalry officer in his youth. He was very religious. He believed, when he became commander of the British forces, that he was being advised by the ghost of Napoleon, which is probably not an ideal thing for a modern general to think. But when he died...
他与宫廷关系很好。年轻时，他是一名意气风发的骑兵军官。他非常虔诚。当他成为英国军队司令时，他相信自己正受到拿破仑幽灵的指引，对于一个现代将军来说，这可能不是一个理想的想法。但当他去世时……
Well, I don't know. I mean, Napoleon was very successful. I mean, it's better than being advised by... The ghost of... Some duffer. Yeah, the ghost of George Duke of Cambridge. Yes, exactly. I mean, imagine... That would be disastrous. Imagine you get a supernatural advisor
好吧，我不知道。我是说，拿破仑非常成功。我是说，这总比被……某个笨蛋的幽灵指引要好。是的，比如剑桥公爵乔治的幽灵。是的，完全没错。我是说，想象一下……那将是灾难性的。想象一下，你得到了一个超自然的顾问，
and it turns out to be him. The worst. The worst general. I mean, that would be a shocker. That would be just bad luck, wouldn't it? Yes. Sort of bring him out in some reality TV show. I mean, I think if you're generally being advised by Napoleon, you probably...
结果证明是他。最糟糕的。最糟糕的将军。我是说，那将是一个震撼。那只能算是运气不好，对吧？是的。有点像在某个真人秀节目中把他请出来。我是说，如果你通常是由拿破仑指导的话，你大概……
Is it like the early rounds of Strictly Come Dancing when they pay you off and they... You've got John Sargent. Yeah. Okay. So, yeah. He died in 1928. There was a colossal turnout for his state funeral. Yeah.
这就像是《严格来跳舞》（Strictly Come Dancing）的前几轮比赛，他们付钱让你走人，然后你……你遇到了约翰·萨金特（John Sargent）。是的。好吧。所以，是的。他于1928年去世。他的国葬场面极其浩大。是的。
He was very popular with the soldiers, like the Victorian generals we talked about last time. But this is not a popular subscription, is it? This is a kind of state-funded... I don't think it is. No, I think it's a state... But I think had there been a popular subscription, there's no doubt he would have had it.
他很受士兵们的欢迎，就像我们上次谈到的维多利亚时代的将军一样。但这并不是公众自愿认捐建造的，对吧？这是一种由国家出资的……我不认为是的。不，我认为这是国家的……但我认为，如果有公众认捐，毫无疑问他也会得到的。
Yeah. Because he was... The soldiers, despite his subsequent reputation, they loved him because he devoted the years after the war to sort of campaigning for their welfare and stuff. Well, I see there's a ring of poppies. There are. If you look, there are actually always poppies by that statue. So, you know, this is an interesting one
是的。因为他……士兵们，尽管他后来名誉受损，但他们都爱戴他，因为他在战后多年里一直致力于为他们的福利等事情奔走呼吁。好吧，我看到那里有一个罂粟花环。确实有。如果你仔细看，那个雕像旁其实一直都有罂粟花。所以，你知道，这是一个很有意思的雕像，
because a lot of people would say Haig's mistakes killed hundreds of thousands of young men. And of course, other people would argue actually he won the war, that his tactics ultimately were vindicated. I don't think there's any argument for cancelling this one, unless you're going to cancel,
因为很多人会说黑格的错误杀害了成千上万的年轻士兵。当然，另一些人会认为实际上是他赢得了战争，他的战术最终得到了证实。我认为没有任何理由取消这个雕像，除非你打算取消……除非你认为第一次世界大战本身是可以被“取消”的。而且，即使你可以争辩说作为一个将军犯错是不能被取消的，当然，因为所有的将军都会犯错。
unless you're arguing that the First World War is kind of cancellable. And even you can argue making mistakes as a general isn't cancellable, surely, because all generals make mistakes. Well mistakes i think that statues that generate heated debate and material for podcasts are good things yeah um so which is why you love the statue of cecil rhodes right i'm not getting onto that um so i reckon anyone interested in the historiography of the first world war you'd want to keep this wouldn't you i i think yeah i think
犯错嘛，我认为能引发激烈争论和为播客提供素材的雕像都是好东西，是的。呃，这就是为什么你那么喜欢塞西尔·罗兹（Cecil Rhodes）的雕像，对吧？我可不想扯到那个上去……呃，所以我想任何对一战史学感兴趣的人，都会想要保留这个雕像，不是吗？我——我想是的。
it would be weird i mean some of our listeners may well say you're talking about military a lot of military men and statues should be opened up beyond that and the celebration of military prowess is is not worth doing i suppose my answer to that would be every society that's ever existed has celebrated um military victory it's a roman thing again yeah i mean it's the legacy that you put up statues to generals who've won wars and in that sense the existence of statues celebrating people who perform great feats or did they debate discuss um in say the first world war is a snapshot of that period yeah agreed this is a little bit of the 1920s yeah that we're at right now yeah as is also well we've got a couple more generals i think tom have we and some quite controversial
这会很奇怪，我是说，我们的一些听众很可能会说：“你们一直在谈论军事，很多军人，雕像应该超越这些，对军事力量的歌颂是不值得做的。”我想我对这一点的回答是：曾经存在过的每一个社会都在歌颂军事胜利。这又是一个罗马式的现象，对吧？我是说，这就是传统所在：你为赢得战争的将军树立雕像；从这个意义上说，存在着歌颂那些取得伟大功绩的人的雕像，或者他们在例如一战中进行了辩论、讨论……这就是那个时期的缩影。是的，同意，这正是20世纪20年代的一小部分，我们现在正身处其中，是的，正如同样……我们还有另外几位将军，我想，汤姆，对吧？还有一些相当有争议的将军，
ones before we get to the cenotaph yeah i was talking oh and we've got um the memorial to the the women of the second world war is that it yeah now we're approaching your brother's territory because your brother of course has this podcast with al murray we have ways of making you talk all about a second world war yes so we're outside the ministry of defense and we have three second world war generals we've got field marshal theount Slim, who campaigned in Burma. Yeah, the Forgotten Army, 14th Army. We've got Alan Brooke. And Monty.
在我们到达阵亡将士纪念碑（Cenotaph）之前。是的，我刚才在说……哦，我们还有第二次世界大战女性纪念碑，是那个吗？是的，现在我们正在接近你兄弟的领地，因为你兄弟当然和阿尔·穆雷（Al Murray）一起主持了这个播客《我们有办法让你开口》（We Have Ways of Making You Talk），全部关于第二次世界大战。是的，所以我们在国防部外面，我们有三位第二次世界大战的将军。我们有在缅甸作战的陆军元帅威廉·斯lim（William Slim）。是的，“被遗忘的军队”，第14集团军。我们有阿兰·布鲁克（Alan Brooke）。还有蒙蒂（Monty）。
And we've got Monty. So let's do Slim first. Lots of people, I understand your brother is a huge admirer of Slim, Slim's generalship. Slim, I've got my notes, he was an ironmonger's son and a former primary school teacher. Was he? Very unusual career trajectory. So he's standing here. He's in his kind of baggy uniform, and he's holding some binoculars.
我们还有蒙蒂。我们先聊聊斯lim。据我所悉，很多人都知道你弟弟非常崇拜斯lim，崇拜斯lim的将帅之才。斯lim——我看了看笔记——他是铁器商的儿子，曾是一名小学教师。是吗？非常不同寻常的职业生涯轨迹。他现在就站在这里。他穿着有些宽松的制服，手里拿着一副双筒望远镜。
But he does have the look of a primary school teacher who's discovered little Johnny. Now, yes, this is an issue doing something naughty in the corner it says at the bottom koima infal arakan which are you know his great victories all the rest of it and it says commander 14th army but at the bottom it says governor general and commander-in-chief in australia now there are allegations that as governor general in australia he interfered with child migrants which the Slim family have bitterly resisted and which have raged in Australia so here you have somebody who ought to be you know an unalloyed hero but there is that kind of well I don't want to say the taint because that sounds like i'm siding with his critics i don't
但他确实有那种发现了小约翰尼的小学教师的神态。现在，对，这就是在角落里干坏事的典型案例，底下写着“科伊马”、“英法尔”、“阿拉干”——你知道的，这是他的伟大胜利等等——上面写着“第十四集团军司令”，但最下面写着“澳大利亚总督兼总司令”。现在有人指控说，他在担任澳大利亚总督期间干涉了英国儿童移民事件，这遭到了斯利姆家族的激烈抵制，并在澳大利亚引发了轩然大波。所以在这里，你本该看到一个无可挑剔的英雄，但却存在这样一种……我不想用“污点”这个词，因为听起来好像我站在他的批评者一边，我对这个问题了解得还不够多，
know enough about the issue but there's at least a question mark i guess um what do you think about that tom well i think that proves the gary young point that um you know don't have any statues ever well the the danger with putting up statues even of the most heroic high achievers is that they will turn out to have feet of clay yes and the whole image of the feet of clay of course is a biblical one thereby proving my point yeah yes again that it's all about christianity so it's amazing how he does it doesn't it yeah so well it's a death maneuver there but i think i i think you see if you work on the assumption of all these statues there are people who are sinners who are people who are okay who are human beings with, but also I would say that it's a monument not just to Slim, but to the people who fought under him. That's why the name's so important, the Arakan and all that stuff.
但至少有一个问号，我想……嗯，汤姆，你对此怎么看？嗯，我认为这证明了加里·扬的观点，那就是……你知道，永远不要立任何雕塑。好吧，树立雕塑的危险，即使是对于最英勇的杰出人物，也是他们最终会被发现脚底有泥。是的，脚底有泥的整个意象当然是一个圣经典故，从而再次证明了我的观点，是的，这全都是关于基督教的。所以这很惊人，他是怎么做到的，对吧？是的，所以……这是一个致命的招数，但我认为……我认为，如果你本着这样的假设去工作：所有这些雕塑中，有罪人，有普通人，他们是有血有肉的人，但同时我也想说，这不仅是对斯利姆的纪念，也是对在他麾下作战的人们的纪念。这就是为什么这个名字如此重要，阿拉干以及所有这些。
So I think that's important. Viscount Alan Brooke. So he was the Chief of the Imperial General Staff, I think. My brother is all over here. We're not going to talk about him. Imagine having that written on your memorial. Dominic, it's pointless us talking about him. staff i think um my brother is all over here yeah we're not going to talk about his much i mean that written on your memorial i dream of that it's it's pointless it's pointless us talking about him let's tell the listeners to go and and listen to my brother i've got a fact about him he's very
所以我认为这很重要。艾伦·布鲁克子爵。所以他曾是帝国总参谋长，我想。我弟弟对这方面了如指掌。我们不打算谈论他。想象一下在你的纪念碑上刻上这样的话。多米尼克，我们谈论他毫无意义。参谋长，我想……我弟弟对这方面了如指掌。对，我们不会过多谈论他。我是说，在你的纪念碑上刻上这样的话，我梦寐以求。谈论他毫无意义，毫无意义。让我们告诉听众去收听我弟弟的节目。我关于他有一个事实，他非常
keen bird watcher yeah like um edward sir edward gray the foreign secretary yeah beginning of the first world war obviously there's a podcast on that tom bird. Birdwatching and World Wars. And then we've got Monty. Yeah. Now, Monty... Who won the Battle of El Alamein. Monty is... Field Marshal, Viscount Montgomery of Alamein. Arguably Britain's... You know, if you're thinking about
热衷于观鸟。是的，就像……爱德华爵士，外交大臣爱德华·格雷爵士，第一次世界大战开始的时候。显然汤姆有一期关于这个的播客。观鸟与世界大战。然后我们有蒙蒂。对。现在，蒙蒂……赢得阿拉曼战役的人。蒙蒂是……陆军元帅，阿拉曼的蒙哥马利子爵。可以说是英国的……你知道，如果你想到
Britain's most famous modern general, I mean, arguably. I mean, it's clearly Monty. Monty's a very peculiar man, though, Tom. You know how he wooed his... So his... When he was in his late 30s, he courted a girl, a 17-year-old girl,
英国最著名的现代将领，我的意思是，可以说。我的意思是，显然是蒙蒂。不过蒙蒂是个很奇怪的人，汤姆。你知道他是怎么追求他的……所以他的……当他快四十岁时，他追求了一个女孩，一个17岁的女孩，
which is quite an age gap. Right. Do you know how he did it? Did he talk to her about... About tanks. He drew tanks in the sand and showed how he would use them in a military engagement. Well, I think that's a reasonable way to court a girl, isn't it?
这年龄差距相当大。没错。你知道他是怎么做到的吗？他跟她谈论……坦克。他在沙地上画坦克，并展示他如何在军事行动中使用它们。嗯，我觉得这是一种追求女孩的合理方式，对吧？
Pro-apartheid, visited South Africa and said how tremendous apartheid was. And also had very strong views about homosexuality. Did he? Was he in favour or not? He said, of the decriminalisation of... Oh, I fell over a barrier. He said, of the decriminalisation of homosexuality, this sort of
亲种族隔离，访问南非并表示种族隔离是多么了不起。而且对同性恋有非常强烈的看法。是吗？他是赞成还是反对？他说，关于……哦，我被一个栏杆绊倒了。他说，关于同性恋非罪化……这种事情也许可以被法国人容忍，但谢天谢地我们是英国人。正如制片人所指出的，关于蒙蒂存在一些疑问……所以是保留还是取消？我想你应该保留，对吧？我是说保留，因为他是阿拉曼的英雄，他是……对，他是阿拉曼的英雄……嗯，但话说回来，这也是因为他……他之所以位列其中，是因为他代表了所有在他麾下战斗过的人，其中一些人还为他战死。你看，这就是我对雕塑的看法，总是存在这样一种假设：为雕塑背书，就等于背书了传主所
thing may be tolerated by the French, but thank god we're british as the producer is pointing out there is some question mark about monty um so keep or cancel i think you keep don't you i mean keep because he's al-alameen he's yeah he's al-alameen yeah um but again it's that he's he's well he again he's up he's up there because he represents all the men who fought under him and some of whom died under him see this is the thing i think about statues there's always this presumption that by endorsing the statue endorse everything the subject
相信的、代表的或说的一切。显然，在蒙哥马利的情况下——你知道的，亲种族隔离、反同性恋——没有人……但通过纪念蒙蒂，我认为你并不是在纪念那些观点。还有，我的意思是，即使在他有生之年，他也被视为怪人，不是吗？哦，大家都觉得他很……对，他们都讨厌他。嗯……但士兵们爱戴他，他是士兵的朋友。如果你看过他在车里的录像或照片，士兵们蜂拥而至，都想跟他握手，哪怕只是瞥一眼……好吧，我明白你的意思了，所以我很高兴保留这三座雕塑。但我确实对它们——对这三座雕塑有意见，因为最初直到2001年左右，这里有一座沃尔特·雷利爵士的雕塑。
believed or stood for or said which obviously in montgomery's case you know pro-apartheid anti-gay nobody but by honoring monty i don't think you're honoring those views also i mean even in his lifetime he was seen as odd wasn't he oh everyone thought he was yeah they all loathed him yeah um but yeah the soldiers loved him he was the soldier's friend if you ever see footage or photos of him in his car and the soldiers are clustering around you don't want to shake his hand and okay get a glimpse yeah i i take your point so i'm very happy to keep all three but i do have i do have something against them against the three of them because originally up until i think 2001 there was a statue here of sir walter raleigh okay um the elizabethan potato yeah um who was um as 1066 and all that said um put in the tower by james the first
好吧……伊丽莎白时代的土豆……嗯，他正如《1066和这一切》中所说的那样，被詹姆斯一世关进塔里，因为他是前朝的遗老……而他……他正是在这个地方被处决的。是吗？对，所以设立这座雕塑是为了标记这个地点……然后他们把它搬走了，基本上是因为他的雕塑——雷利的雕塑太矮了，所以跟第二次世界大战的将军们相比，他看起来像个滑稽的侏儒。对，所以有点对此感到不满，但雷利已经被搬到格林威治了。所以，汤姆，关于第二次世界大战的将军们，我注意到在这个播客中，到目前为止我们只讲了男性，所以你有什么女性人物可以讲吗？这是我经常问你的问题，多米尼克。我很高兴你问我这个问题。我没有。
for being left over from the previous reign um and he was um he was executed on on this spot was he yeah so the statue was put here to mark the spot um and then they moved it basically because the statue of him the statue of raleigh was too too short so he looked kind of comically dwarfish right compared to the second world war generals yeah so slightly resentful of that but raleigh's been moved to greenwich so tom second world war generals i'm conscious that in this podcast we've done only men so far so have you any women for me a question i often ask you dominic i'm so glad you asked me that question. I don't.
你没有？不，我没有。但我确实有一座第二次世界大战女性纪念碑，上面其实并没有任何女性形象。上面只有她们的……哦，对，那是一个非常、非常……对，只有她们的衣服。所以那是她们的……
You don't? No, I don't. But I do have a monument to the women of World War II, which doesn't actually have any women on it. It just has their... Oh, yeah, that's a very, very... Yeah, it's just their clothes. So it's their...
我想大概是土地女孩和……对，土地女孩，没错，还有救护车司机。女子海军陆战队之类的人。女子海军陆战队，没错。她们的制服和衣服挂在一个大方块上。所以那是……这显然与纪念碑（Cenotaph）相对应，纪念碑就在白厅稍远一点的地方，我想那是……
I guess it's kind of land girls and... Yeah, land girls, exactly, and ambulance drivers. Wrens and things like that. Wrens, exactly. And their uniforms and clothes hanging from a kind of great block. So that's... And it's obviously a counterpart to the Cenotaph, which is just a bit further down Whitehall, which I guess is the...
我的意思是，那是建立的……所以那是勒琴斯设计的，是为了纪念第一次世界大战而建立的，至今仍是全民族纪念活动的年度焦点。让我们向中心走去。但我只想说说第二次世界大战女性纪念碑上的文字。“World War II”（第二次世界大战），我的意思是，我认为这是一个美国化词汇。
I mean, that was raised... So that's designed by Lutyens and it's raised to commemorate the First World War and it's still the annual focus of the nation's remembrance. Let's walk towards the centre. But I just wanted to say about the lettering on the monument to the women of World War II. World War II, I mean, that's an Americanism, I think.
这是一个续集，不是吗？第二次世界大战，续集。阿尔·默里的笑话。对。但是，我的意思是，这有点不光彩，不是吗？我……二战，续集，阿尔·默里的笑话。对，但我的意思是，这有点不光彩，不是吗？嗯……我大概可以接受这一点，我想“第二次世界大战”这几个字塞不进墙上，他们得改变字体，那会是一件非常麻烦的事。嗯，我认为“二战女性纪念碑”其实是一座伟大的纪念碑，它很聪明，它……你知道，与其他纪念碑相比，它很显眼。它确实如此。而且这种背景，这种军国主义的、纯男性的背景，让它更具力量。
It's a sequel, isn't it? World War II, the sequel. The Al Murray joke. Yeah. But, I mean, that's kind of disgraceful, isn't it? I ii the sequel the al murray joke yeah um but i mean that's kind of disgraceful isn't it um i can kind of live for that i suppose the second world war wouldn't fit on the on the side of the war they'd have to change the font and that would be a terrible faff um i think the women of world war ii is a great monument actually it's clever it's it's you know it stands out compared with the others it It really does. And it's the context, the militaristic, the all-male context makes it all the more powerful.
对，我同意。它与阵亡将士纪念碑相得益彰。我认为一座纪念碑能与阵亡将士纪念碑相媲美，这相当了不起。现在，我想——我不知道你是否同意我的看法，但我认为阵亡将士纪念碑是一件了不起的公共艺术品。我认为是因为它不是具象的。对，同意。而且因为它实际上……具象的，对，同意。而且因为它实际上在某种程度上出人意料地低调，它并不咄咄逼人，它的
Yeah, I agree. And it complements the Cenotaph. And I think for a monument to complement the Cenotaph is quite something. Now, I think, I don't know if you'd agree with me, but I think the Cenotaph is an amazing bit of public art. I think because it's not figurative. Yeah, agreed. And because it's actually figurative yeah agreed and because it's actually surprisingly modest in a way it's not overpowering um it's kind of moving in its
简朴有一种动人的力量，你知道的，正如你所说，它就像建在柱基上的某种祭坛之类的东西；它的一端写着“光荣的死难者”。它建于1920年并最终完工。它并没有走向极端爱国主义。它本质上不是一座狭隘的民族主义纪念碑。这也是这两个播客中，汤姆，人们真的在注视它的第一座雕塑。是的。所以有一个带着几个小孩子的家庭去参观它，
simplicity you know as you say it's like a sort of altar or something built up on a plinth um it says the glorious dead at one end it It was built in, finalized in 1920. It doesn't go overboard with the patriotism. It's not an inherently nationalistic monument. It's also the first statue in either of these podcasts, Tom, where there are people actually looking at it. Yeah. So there's a family with very small children going to look at it,
这实际上，我认为，在某种程度上是一个相当感人的景象。他们刚刚敬献了一个花环，我想。现在有个小女孩正走回那里。是的。是的，还有一个小女孩坐在台阶上。你看，我觉得这很可爱。我认为这就是公共艺术、历史艺术所做的事情。当然，人们不会在查尔斯·纳皮尔爵士的雕塑前这样做。
which is actually, I think, in its way, quite a sort of moving sight. And they just laid a wreath, I think. There's a little girl going back there now. Yeah. Yeah, and there's a little girl sitting on the steps. You see, I think that's lovely. And I think that is what public art, historic art does. I mean, of course, people aren't doing that at the Statue of Charles Napier.
如果他们那样做的话，那才叫相当怪异呢。但我认为这是非常感人的，你知道，在它建成101年后，人们仍然去参观它，并且去……我的意思是，基本上它吸引人们注意这样一种方式：我们看过的所有雕塑都是单人形象的，所以没有一种共同体感，没有一种向所有牺牲的人或其他什么人致敬的感觉，而阵亡将士纪念碑通过完全不展示任何人物来做到这一点。阵亡将士纪念碑，这意味着空坟墓，对吧？是的，所以？是的。所以我说它是一个祭坛，但它不是一个祭坛。它是顶部的一个坟墓，柱基上的一个坟墓，高高凌驾于交通之上。
It would be pretty bizarre if they were but i think that is very moving that you know 101 years after it was built people are still going to visit it and to sort of i mean basically it it draws attention to the way in which um all the statues that we've looked at have been of single figures so there isn't a sense of of the commonality there isn't a sense of um tribute being paid to you know all the art people who've died or whatever whereas the cenotaph does that simply by not showing any figures at all cenotaph that means empty tomb does it yeah so? Yeah. So I said it was an altar, but it's not an altar. It's a tomb on the top, a tomb on the plinth, elevated above the traffic.
而且我确实认为，我同意你的看法。我认为，正如上面所写的那样，正如铭文所读的那样，它是“光荣的死难者”。我的意思是，它代表了在第一次世界大战中阵亡的每一个人。我认为这比任何单一形象都要强大得多。是的。好吧，我们绝对会保留那个。好吧，所以那个想……是的。好吧。我们绝对会保留那个。好吧。
And I do think, I agree with you. I think, as it says, it's the glorious dead, as the inscription reads. I mean, it represents everybody who fell in the First World War. And that's more powerful than a single figure could ever be, I think. Yeah. Okay, we'll definitely keeping that. Okay, so that think. Yeah. Okay. We're definitely keeping that. Okay.
所以那绝对不是要取消。我们应该休息一下。然后前往国会广场。国会广场。很好。一会儿见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。
So that's definitely not a cancel. We should take a break. And then head to Parliament Square. Parliament Square. Very good. See you in a minute. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
我们共同主持《娱乐就是一切》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一丝好莱坞八卦的固定栏目。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告节目、获取额外单集以及提前购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史就是一切》（The Rest Is History），我们在谈论雕塑。我们正在阳光明媚的小路上散步
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History history we're talking about statues we were on a lovely sunlit walk
沿着白厅走向国会广场，汤姆·霍兰德以一种对我来说并不陌生的方式坚持我们要拐个弯，现在我们在一个阳光明媚的伦敦日里的树荫下。我们在一个用木板封起来的商店旁潜伏着，看着对面的大本钟被脚手架覆盖，以及……汤姆，那是谁的雕塑？布狄卡女王的雕塑。我把你拉到这里的理由是，我认为这座雕塑最有趣，因为它是我们看过的所有雕塑中最具悖论性的雕塑。所以，为了我们那些不知道布狄卡是谁的听众。所以布狄卡，布狄卡，也就是中世纪所知的博迪西亚（Bodecia），
down whitehall heading for parliament square and tom holland in his not unfamiliar way to me at least has insisted that we take a dog leg and we're now standing in the shade on a beautiful sunny london day we're lurking by a boarded up shop, looking across at Big Ben covered with scaffolding and a statue of who, Tom? Of Queen Boudicca. And the reason I wanted to drag you here is that I think that this statue is the most interesting because the most paradoxical statue of any that we have looked at. So for our listeners who don't know who Boudicca was. So Boudicca, Boudicca, Bodecia, as she was known in the Middle Ages,
沿着白厅走向议会广场，汤姆·霍兰德以一种对我来说并不陌生的方式坚持要我们绕个弯，现在我们在这个阳光明媚、美丽迷人的伦敦日子的树荫下，潜伏在一个用木板封起来的店面旁，眺望着被脚手架覆盖的大本钟以及一座雕像，那是谁的，汤姆？布狄卡女王的。我把你拉到这里来的原因，是因为我认为这座雕像是我们看过的所有雕像中最有趣、也最矛盾的雕像。所以，对于那些不知道布狄卡是谁的听众来说。那么，布狄卡，布狄卡，也就是中世纪时人们所知的博迪西亚，
as she was known quite popularly up until quite recently, was the queen of the Icani, which was a British tribe that rose in revolt against the Romans in the early years of the Roman occupation. Yeah. Was her daughters raped or something? So her daughters were raped against the Romans in the early years of the Roman occupation. Yeah. Weren't her daughters raped or something? So her daughters were raped by the Romans. Boudicca was beaten. And such was her fury and shame that she led her tribe on a murderous rampage
正如直到最近还广为人知的那样，她是爱西尼人（Icani）的女王，这是一个在罗马占领早期发起反对罗马人起义的英国部落。是的。她的女儿们被强奸了吗？所以她的女儿们在罗马占领早期被罗马人强奸了。布狄卡被殴打。她的愤怒和羞耻感如此之强烈，以至于她带领她的部落进行了一场血腥的暴走，
that incinerated Colchester, the capital of Roman Britain as it was then, and then descended on London. And torched London. And to this day, archaeologists can trace the devastation that she brought in the kind of the black soil that it left. So there's an incredible paradox in the fact that you have a queen who incinerated London in one of the most iconic spots in the whole of the capital, because she's on the end of Westminster Bridge looking up at Big Ben. So everybody who comes here will see her. She's in a chariot.
焚毁了科尔切斯特——当时的罗马不列颠首都——然后向伦敦进军。并烧毁了伦敦。直到今天，考古学家仍然可以从它留下的黑土中追溯到她带来的破坏。因此，在一个首都所有最具标志性的地点之一，你有一位焚毁了伦敦的女王，这其中存在着令人难以置信的悖论，因为她位于威斯敏斯特桥的尽头，抬头看着大本钟。所以所有来到这里的人都会看到她。她坐在一辆战车上。
She's got scythes on the chariot wheels, which she didn't have, but was a popular legend. She's got her daughters with her. Boudicca, in the Celtic language that she spoke, meant victory, Victoria. But she didn't win. So this is also a portrait of Victoria, Queen Victoria. So it's raised in honour of Queen Victoria.
战车轮上有镰刀，虽然她实际上并没有，但这在传说中很受欢迎。她的女儿们和她在一起。在布狄卡所说的凯尔特语中，布狄卡意味着胜利（victory, Victoria）。但她并没有赢。所以这也是维多利亚女王的肖像。因此，这是为纪念维多利亚女王而建立的。
So there's all kinds of complications here. We've talked about the ambivalences that this kind of Roman inheritance of statuary provokes for people. So when we look at the statue of Boudichica are we doing so as britons or as as romans are we identifying with the romans who founded london so in a sense if you're a londoner you are an heir of of the romans or are you looking at her as as a britain as a member of the oppressed people and bearing in mind that this was put up in the heyday of the british empire yeah the ambivalence is a huge because yeah is this a monument to british imperialism or is it a question mark being raised over the depredations of imperial occupation very nicely done so i think that this channels all the tensions and paradoxes and complications
所以这里有各种各样的复杂情况。我们讨论过这种罗马雕像遗产给人们带来的矛盾心理。所以当我们看着布狄卡的雕塑时，我们是以英国人的身份还是以罗马人的身份？我们是在认同建立伦敦的罗马人吗？从某种意义上说，如果你是一个伦敦人，你就是罗马人的继承人；或者你是在以一个英国人的身份、一个受压迫人民成员的身份看着她？考虑到这是在大英帝国全盛时期建立的，这种矛盾心理是巨大的，因为这究竟是英国帝国主义的纪念碑，还是对帝国占领掠夺行为提出的一个问号？做得非常好。
that i suspect that when we go to parliament square we're also going to be looking at. It's a demonstration, it's an embodiment of the fact that all these works of public art have multiple meanings. Absolutely. To an extent, you project onto that what you want to see in it. But I will say this, an awful lot of people, since you've been talking, I mean, obviously, I've noticed loads of people looking at you and whispering to each other, that TV's Tom Holland and the rest is history. But I can't help noticing that nobody has looked at the statue. No, there's a gentleman there just looked up at it. Yeah, I think he was looking at the sky. No, I don't think so.
所以我认为这引导了所有的紧张关系、悖论和复杂性，我猜当我们去国会广场时，我们也会看到这些。这是一个证明，是所有这些公共艺术作品具有多重含义的体现。绝对是。在某种程度上，你把你想在其中看到的东西投射到它上面。但我得说，自从你说话以来，有相当多的人——我的意思是，很明显，我注意到许多人看着你并互相低语，那是电视上的汤姆·霍兰德和《历史就是一切》。但我忍不住注意到没有人看着那座雕塑。不，那边有一位绅士刚刚抬头看着它。对，我想他在看天空。不，我不这么认为。
I think he was at my... It's a splendid statue. It is. It's a very nice piece of... She's got a crown. She's holding a spear. Yes. Her horses are rising up. It's everything. And it's actually part of a whole tradition of European statuary
我想他在看我……这是一座极好的雕塑。确实是的。这是一件非常好的……她戴着王冠。她手里拿着一根长矛。是的。她的马腾空而起。应有尽有。这其实是整个欧洲雕塑传统的一部分，
which asks exactly this question. So in France, you have statues of Vercingetorix, the Gallic leader who fought against the Romans. In Germany, you've got statues of Arminius, who again defeated Rome. But of course, these statues are themselves absolutely in the Roman tradition. So it's an interrogation of the inheritance of Roman statuary, which I think is fascinating. What we haven't talked about at all, Tom, is the importance of statues to kind of nation building and a sense of national identity and a national story. So the classic example of this, I always think,
它恰恰提出了这个问题。所以在法国，你有对罗马人作战的高卢领袖韦尔金盖托里克斯的雕塑。在德国，你有再次击败罗马的阿米尼乌斯的雕塑。但当然，这些雕塑本身完全处于罗马传统之中。所以这是对罗马雕塑遗产的一种审视，我认为这非常迷人。汤姆，我们完全没有讨论过的是雕塑对于国家建设、国家认同感和国家历史的重要性。对此的经典例子，我总觉得，
I did a rival podcast series, a limited series, a couple of years ago, in which it was about invented history. It's called Hijacked Histories. And the final episode, we went to the republic of north macedonia as it now is where they famously have got into enormous rows with their neighbors the greeks because they put up statues of alexander the great and philip of macedon and claimed that these people were theirs and that they own them and people have always laughed at the the Macedonians because they put up billions of statues in Skopje, their capital. And it looks like a sort of statue of Disneyland now. But actually, although it's easy to laugh at them,
几年前我做了一个竞争性的播客系列，一个短系列，是关于被篡改的历史的。它叫《劫持历史》（Hijacked Histories）。最后一集，我们去了现在被称为北马其顿共和国的地方，他们因竖立亚历山大大帝和马其顿的腓力二世的雕塑并声称这些人是他们的、他们拥有这些人，而与邻国希腊人陷入了巨大的争端。人们总是嘲笑马其顿人，因为他们在他们的首都斯科普里竖立了数十亿座雕塑。现在它看起来有点像迪斯尼乐园的雕塑。但实际上，尽管嘲笑他们很容易，
I kind of think putting up statues in the Western world is what you do. It's to tell your national story. You write it in stone and bronze, and that's actually just part of the sort of the canon of nation building if you like and it's a particularly greek thing because they're the the people who start it really yeah um you know that's the that's the great inheritance uh and i remember when we were doing um the podcast with michael wood on china the question of whether the um the the Terracotta army was influenced by
我倒觉得在西方世界树立雕塑是你必须做的事。这是为了讲述你的国家历史。你把它写在石头和青铜上，这实际上只是国家建设准则的一部分，如果你愿意这么说的话，这是一种特别希腊化的东西，因为他们是真正开始这一切的人。对……你知道，那是伟大的遗产。我记得当我们和迈克尔·伍德一起做关于中国的播客时，关于……兵马俑是否受到希腊具象雕塑模型影响的问题。我认为印度的情况肯定也是如此，尽管中世纪印度绝对有本土雕塑国王的传统，但穆斯林的到来显然重塑了这一传统。所以你没有莫卧儿王朝的雕塑形象。因此，从某种意义上说，印度现代具象肖像雕塑的传统，具有讽刺意味的是，就像布狄卡的雕塑一样，是来自罗马殖民者的遗产，而描绘印度自由战士的雕塑则是来自英国帝国主义者的遗产。所以这是一种巨大的文化影响和文化拒绝的交织。现在，汤姆，我们走过却没谈论的两个半身像，是红狮酒吧的查尔斯·狄更斯和杰弗里·乔叟。
that Greek model of figurative statue. And I think it's certainly the case, say, in India, although there were absolutely kind of native traditions of sculpting kings in medieval India, the coming of the Muslims obviously irradiated that tradition. So you don't have sculptural representation, say, of the moguls. So in a sense, the modern tradition of figurative portraiture of sculpture in India, ironically, rather like the statue of Boudicca is an inheritance from the Roman colonialists, the statue portraying Indian freedom fighters is an inheritance from the British imperialists. So it's a kind of massive strip of cultural influence and cultural rejection. Now, Tom, two busts that we didn't talk about that we walked past are the Red Lion Pub, Charles Dickens and Geoffrey Chaucer.
那种希腊式的具象雕像模范。我认为情况确实如此，比方说在印度，尽管中世纪的印度绝对存在雕刻国王的本土传统，但穆斯林的到来显然打破了那一传统。所以你不会看到例如莫卧儿王朝的雕塑形象。因此从某种意义上说，印度现代具象肖像雕塑的传统，具有讽刺意味的是，就像布狄卡雕像一样，是继承自罗马殖民者，而描绘印度自由斗士的雕像则是继承自英国帝国主义者。所以这是一种巨大的文化影响与文化抗拒的交织。现在，汤姆，我们走过却没有谈论的两个半身像是红狮酒吧的查尔斯·狄更斯和杰弗里·乔叟。
And they're the only two writers that we've passed so far. So that's the massive gap, isn't it? So we've looked at people basically who who you know with the odd exception get their statues put up because they've killed people which is very greek and roman very greek and roman yes although the greeks and romans had statues of their great writers of course yeah um and that is something that we we don't have um i think dickens so dickens is probably the writer who more than anyone else... Well, Shakespeare. No, but it symbolises London.
而且他们是我们到目前为止唯一经过的两位作家。所以这是一个巨大的鸿沟，不是吗？所以我们基本上看的是那些除了个别例外，因为杀过人而被树立雕像的人，这非常希腊和罗马，非常希腊和罗马，是的，尽管希腊和罗马当然也有伟大作家的雕像，是的，嗯，这是我们所没有的，嗯，我认为狄更斯，所以狄更斯可能是比其他人更能……嗯，莎士比亚。不，但它象征着伦敦。
OK, yes, yes, yes. Our image of London is completely fashioned by Dickens. And I think Dickens requested that there be no statues of him put up. So I would guess that's the reason that there aren't statues of him. But Chaucer also, huge influence on how we see London, because the Canterbury Tales begins with people meeting in a pub in Southwark, on the South Bank of the Thames. And this really powerfully struck me during the pandemic,
好的，是的，是的，是的。我们对伦敦的印象完全是由狄更斯塑造的。我想狄更斯曾要求不要为他树立雕像。所以我想这就是为什么没有他的雕像的原因。但乔叟也对我们如何看待伦敦有着巨大的影响，因为《坎特伯雷故事集》以人们在南华克泰晤士河南岸的一家酒馆相遇开始。这在疫情期间深深地震撼了我，
because I was meant to be, that April last year, I was meant to be walking across Kent with my brother, just as the Canterbury Pilgrims did. Of course, couldn't do that because of the pandemic and the lockdown. So I began reading Canterbury Tales. And it struck me completely afresh, the excitement of it, because Chaucer is writing at a time where the plague is endemic in London and it would be particularly endemic over the winter. So you would perhaps isolate, self-isolate over the winter. And then the whole thing about the joy of not socially distancing and meeting up with strangers in a pub and setting out across the spring with the birds singing and the sweet showers across Kent. It kind of filled me with this wistful yearning. And I say one of the things that I did over the lockdown was to follow in Chaucer's footsteps across South London. And for me, Chaucer and Dickens are far more vivid
因为我原本打算在去年四月和我哥哥一起穿过肯特郡步行，就像坎特伯雷朝圣者那样。当然，由于疫情和封锁，没能做到这一点。于是我开始阅读《坎特伯雷故事集》。它以全新面貌深深打动了我，那种兴奋感，因为乔叟写作的时代正值瘟疫在伦敦流行，而且在冬季尤为严重。所以你可能会在冬天进行隔离，自我隔离。然后那种不用保持社交距离、在酒馆里与陌生人相遇、在春天鸟儿歌唱和肯特郡阵阵甘霖中出发的快乐。它让我心中充满了这种依恋的渴望。我说我在封锁期间做的事情之一就是沿着乔叟的足迹走过伦敦南部。对我来说，乔叟和狄更斯要生动得多
representations, not just of London, but of England than any of the figures that we've looked at. I think that's probably fair. I think that's very fair. I think if you were redesigning Whitehall, if you were told to redesign Whitehall and to line it with statues to symbolise England or Britain and you weren't allowed military leaders, or indeed if you just started from scratch... I'd keep Nelson. I mean, I think Nelson is a
不仅是伦敦，而且是英国的写照，远胜于我们看过的任何其他人物。我认为这很公正。我认为这非常公正。我想如果你重新设计白厅，如果有人叫你重新设计白厅并用象征英国或大不列颠的雕像排成一行，而且不允许出现军事将领，或者如果你真的从头开始……我会留着纳尔逊。我的意思是，我认为纳尔逊是一个
kind of charismatic figure. I wouldn't. I mean, nothing to me. Yeah, but you definitely have dickinson short and newton and i mean it's odd that we don't know scientists i suppose i'd have jenna i could keep saying yeah he's mad about jenna anyway um tom we always intended to get to parliament square we've been promising that for about a lot for the last two podcasts and we've gone on far too long because a we're we're slow walkers, and, B, you talk too much. That is the truth.
富有魅力的迷人人物。我不会。我是说，对我来说没什么。是的，但你绝对会有狄更斯、肖和牛顿，而且我觉得我们不了解科学家很奇怪，我想我会留着琴纳，我一直在说，是的，他迷恋琴纳，无论如何，汤姆，我们一直打算去议会广场，我们在过去的两期播客里已经承诺过好久了，而且我们说了太久，因为 A，我们走得慢，B，你话太多。这就是事实。
You've been going on about all these weird Elizabethan, I mean, Edwardian generals and their mistresses. Well, I think we've both been talking too much. I think we can all get that. Yeah, we've been wibbling on. So we should do Parliament Square in the third part of this mighty trilogy. And in Parliament Square, of course, you get to the big guns. You get to Lloyd George, Churchill, Mandela, Gandhi, Millicent Fawcett,
你一直在说那些奇怪的伊丽莎白时代，我是说，爱德华时代的将领和他们的情妇。嗯，我觉得我们俩话都太多了。我想大家都能看出来。是的，我们一直在唠叨。所以我们应该在这部宏伟三部曲的第三部分中讲讲议会广场。当然，在议会广场，你会看到真正的大人物。你会看到劳合·乔治、丘吉尔、曼德拉、甘地、米利森特·福塞特，
and the Earl of Derby. Oh, I know, everybody is. And Cromwell. Yes, Cromwell's come. And Richard I. Oh, very good. So we will do that in the return of the Jedi of this podcasting triptych on Parliament Square, and we will see you next time. Yeah, see you.
以及德比伯爵。哦，我知道，每个人都是。还有克伦威尔。是的，克伦威尔也来了。还有理查一世。哦，非常好。所以我们将在议会广场这一播客三部曲的《绝地归来》中做到这一点，我们下次再见。好的，再见。
Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听奖励单集、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。